don't you know that islam forgives
everything you think it's the tattoo
that's stopping you you think it's a
jahalia that's stopping you
or is it you sincerely turning back to
allah
is it you having the humility to own
your mistakes and say allah
i'm ready to come to you allah i'm ready
to start fresh allah
let's make this happen let me submit to
you ya rabi
because i was wrong but now i'm ready to
write my wrongs which one is it
because allah is ready to forgive you
the question is are you ready to ask for
that forgiveness
[Music]
he would think ah yeah like my plan is
aligned with the loss plan because
everything is functioning so
smoothly but then out of nowhere there's
a sticking point and like nothing's
happening
and to him he's like going crazy and he
he's
pretty much second out or second
guessing doubting
and uh just chaotic for like a better
words
but it's in that time where he needs to
be as
patient as possible and continue to
trust
in the creator and continue to do
whatever it is he started
doing keeping the same energy that he
started with
in order for him to pass the test
with dear brothers and sisters welcome
back to the videos podcasting dunya
you're here with the three hosts and we
got a special guest
sq6b2 what'd he do oh
you already know how you doing brother
i'm doing love bro i see i see you got
that
light skin look on your head i see that
i see you got that light skin you came
in with that intro like nice and soft
okay i see that i like that i like that
intro baby yes sir
yes sir so for today's uh
podcast fight why don't you uh cue the
man what are we going into today
yeah why don't you tell them what i told
you before i don't remember anything you
told me
bro to be honest we're just gonna
freestyle with sq
yeah so all right when i found you i
don't remember how
uh oh wait i do bro it's sq so it's
gonna be some clickbaity title
some clickbaity know
any thumbnails and titles
sensationalized because that's what we
need
why not it works good though was the
video good though that's the question
it was really good bro yeah mashallah
and it was it was something like just
you know asking non-muslims or strangers
about islam one of those right
it was i think it was quitting strangers
in new york for an ipad i believe
something like that or
some airpods or something like that okay
and i saw it and i was like bro
me going in i'm like bro these
non-muslims they're not gonna know
anything they're not gonna know the
answers because
you're not asking basic questions like
uh
for example uh do muslims pray
yes or no no it was like it was more in
depth and a lot of them got the answers
on point there was one too where there
was a guy he was like
it was really hype and i like the way
you did it it makes non-muslim audiences
really follow and learn something but in
an emotional provocative way
so they won't forget it right okay
mashallah i appreciate that man i'm
happy that you got to
view that video um that's just one of
obviously many that i have out there
but at the same time it's just one of
those
videos that i always wanted to do you
know and i'm waiting
bro last time i just went to times
square to do this ps5 video but
it started raining on me so i couldn't
really do that but inshallah for eid
i have a really nice video coming out in
childline that we're going to fall
asleep as well too so there's a lot of
projects going on right now so just just
stay tuned there's a lot of videos there
but
i'm humbled by your kindness bro thank
you for clicking i appreciate you
watching and uh
and leading on to another another thing
or another two things or not but i
appreciate you guys man
yeah don't bro don't ever feel any type
of way either
for uh working the system and doing the
uh
clickbaity stuff because it's like dude
yeah at the end of the day
your intention is there and you're
spreading dawa in a way
that's actually working the system
because you already know how youtube is
you already know how social media is
this it's just the way people work
it's a psychology and you're tapping
into it bro
so don't assume for sure bro and you
know what honestly
i don't i don't feel like in the
beginning
i guess like way back when i used to
feel like you know people will go excuse
you clickbait like am i really though
like you're clicking on something you're
enjoying the content behind it so
i don't think i really was uh but if
there's a really catchy thumbnail look
i'm competing against how many
people right for you the scroll how many
times do you go through your youtube
feed
and scroll through a video and you don't
even click it every day
i'm competing with that you know i'm
complete with that and then on top of it
i'm trying to
basically help muslims rediscover their
and develop their islamic identity
it's not an easy thing to do so i need
to make sure that i'm doing it the most
and
bro there's i don't care how clickbaity
it is you know at the end their views
and everything comes from allah
i have so many other videos that are
click-baity but they don't have the same
amount of views or impact that that
video one
video has so it's not even about that
even you could have the best thumbnail
the best title
everything going for you but it's in the
hands of allah at the end then you just
can't be stressing it too much
you just got to be aggressive and just
put the content out and just make it a
banger and allah sorts out the rest
that's facts
and all your projects i mean
thank you thank you and same for you
guys man i know i see you guys grinding
on the youtube scene as well
you guys are working hard masha'allah i
like that you know i always respect the
hustle and the grind of people who
are you know just going against all odds
you guys are making a name for yourself
you guys are getting some great guests
masha'allah
like you know it clearly is catching
some traction and i'm just happy for
your future guys and i'm i'm really
excited for that
i ask allah to you know not only accept
your actions but elevate you guys
when i first came across your content or
at least when it first really you know
hit me
um it was your river story or or you
know you're
at least coming to islam story because
not everyone who comes to islam you know
is necessarily a reaver from like myself
for example 5 for example
we were born into islam but it never
really clicked for us and you know until
later in life
so i heard the stories he went to uh to
pakistan and
you know it was during ramadan and you
felt you know the vibes there and and
you know the rest is history
surprisingly i appreciate rami mehrami
going
in right now okay probably doing some
some real note taking i i appreciate
that
i really like the video was just so the
story was so well told mashaallah just
one of those you know stories that stick
with you subhanallah so
um really it really hit me because i
didn't have a similar
experience but you know when you hear a
story like that you're just like
subhanallah you know you take the
so many of us take the deen for granted
and
to turn this into a question because i
want to get your opinion on this
let's say there are brothers out there
in a similar situation we're like
they're muslim
but it's more by more of muslim by name
less by action so what would you say to
brothers looking to you know discover
their dna you know to to get on to islam
insha allah to fully submit to allah
bismuth
uh you know what bro i think that one
thing that's interesting about me and
i'm not that interesting but like one
position that i play
really well alhamdulillah is um if a
person
is doing the ja helia i have enough
experience to let you know what it's all
about and to call you back
if that makes sense uh if a person is
interested in doing the jahidia they can
live vicariously through
me so they don't have to experience that
pain and that turmoil that a person goes
through and coming back to the beam so
i feel like i play this role where a
person who's not on the beam can see
someone as
a example to come back and i think that
there's way better examples than me out
there you know i would never
claim that i am the best one but there's
so many other examples out there but
i like to think of it more from the
perspective of you know like i
understand people
to a degree where i know what they're
going through and because i can vibe
with them a little bit i can relate to
them i think it makes them a little bit
more easier to come back but
going back to the question that you're
talking about about how do you call
someone back
i think that it really comes down to
valuing allah
valuing your salah and a lot of times
people don't have
values when it comes to these things
like you know they might appreciate it
but they don't value it and
you know think about something that
you've ever valued right like i remember
valuing a specific sneaker drop that
would come out and i'd be in those lines
bro at the hudget time forget all that
the hudson time before the hundred times
waiting in line for like the latest
jordan drop or whatever it is i was
looking for at the time
is because i valued that more than i
valued my sleep you feel me
so i valued these things hence i made an
extra effort
i wasn't lazy with it you know i valued
what i was going to get from me waking
up early to do that so
any person who's not really on their
deen right now
because that could change in a heartbeat
the same way the magicians
changed in a heartbeat when they saw
musa alayhi salaam it could change
the heart is very soft and it could turn
by the permission of allah
i would say that you're feeling lazy
towards your salah
because you don't value your salah you
don't value what it has to offer
to you because if you and i start
counting the times how much
the hajj helped us out how much is salah
helped us out we'd be like yo
we know it's a winner that's how we keep
going back to it you feel me like we
keep
repeating that process because we know
how powerful it is
because we've seen the miracles that
came from it so my advice to someone
would be
don't go to salah i say like you know
you're going to get something from it
the real question is what can you give
what can you give to the salah and
for those of us who are living in the
jahiliyyah in that really you know fast
lane as i like to call it sometimes
you know salah really slows you down it
calms you down and it helps you in
whatever you're doing so
even if you're just using salah to help
yourself out i think a person should
just approach it
yeah yeah yes
you know reminds me of something my
teacher uh told us that he actually
he heard from uh and it was basically
you know a lot of people
who have not mental illnesses but you
know they're mentally strained in some
ways they're mentally exhausted
um they try all these different um acts
like you know meditation and all these
different things and
no i'm not gonna say they don't work but
um one
tip he gave us is you know take at least
one prayer of the day
and when you pray it pray it nice and
slow
read take your time even if it takes you
five minutes to read sort of
fatiha alone take your time with it and
and really focus on it and i did that
just
once and subhan allah the the
tranquility
and the the contentment that you feel
after something like that is so
beautiful subhanallah and it just it it
begs
one question which is you know like how
many people are missing out on something
like that it's kind of like because
we're so caught in what's being sold to
us facts
that we ignore you know subhanallah what
we have easy access to
and uh what's most beneficial to us
and you know the truth is my bro is that
people are missing out
all because of themselves you know i
mean like there's something amazing
literally a quran you know you know
calmness to the person's heart it's
sitting right there but you're not going
to it
the salah is right there you could bow
your head just one time and feel the
calmness but
if you're not approaching it it just
shows that allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
is keeping something away from you
there's something about us that we got
to purify
some testia there's something about us
that's stopping us from picking up that
quran
anyone who's out there not reading quran
thinking that it's up to them and their
choice
that's what you think because you're
gassed up you think wrong the truth is
allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is not
allowing your hands to touch
the most blessed mushaf the blessed
pages in the
world because there's something with you
there's an
intention that you got to come with this
salah because it
it sort of unravels itself for you when
you come with the right mia the right
intention
if you come to it like all right i'll
just try it out i did it it doesn't work
there's so many people like that i tried
to pray it didn't work sq or i tried to
read the quran and did nothing for me
because you ask and you shall find and
whatever you look for you're going to
find and whatever you don't look for in
earnest
kind of fine too you know you're not
really looking for the answer you're
just you know playing the role like you
did it
but the truth of the matter is that when
you're actually trying it out like
you're scott your
your teacher told you my bro to try it
out you tried it out with all
earnestness and look how it helped you
versus a skeptic
a person who doesn't really believe but
not even like in the religion but
believe
in this advice they tried like yo i
tried it it didn't work like nah you
didn't try right
true story the man came to the messenger
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
and he complained about a headache just
a regular headache
so the messenger sallallahu alaihi
sallam told him listen
have some honey and come back you'll
feel better right we know
honey has shifa black seeds have shifa
zamzam
there's so much you know in the sunnah
prophetic ways
so the man goes back home comes back to
the messenger salsa and complains
it didn't work my head still hurts the
messenger sallallahu
asalam said that your head has lied to
you your body has lied to you
try it again so he goes back he does it
and he comes back same results he said
no
that your head is lied to you go try it
again until he kept doing it until he
comes back to the prophet
and says ya rasulallah my headache is
cured and then he tells him that your
body has told the truth
when we approach something with true
appreciation true belief
believe me it will work because it is
from the sunnah it is from allah
azzawajal
but if you approach it as a skeptic it's
not going to work for you it's not going
to unravel and unlock itself for you
subhanallah that's that's really
profound you know it really uh
it really puts into perspectives behind
a lot um i heard this this story
once um they reminded me of it um
where a man went to work and everyone at
work it was like an experiment
everyone he passed by said oh you look
sick today you look sick today you look
sick today
and at first he's like no i'm fine i'm
fine you know otherwise like yeah i'm
feeling a little ill
after five six people maybe he's like
you know i i am feeling a bit sick i you
know i think i need to go home
and it's like subhanallah you know his
body literally tricked him into thinking
that he's sick
and it's very similar to the hadith the
process i'm going to paraphrase because
i don't remember exactly but he
basically said um
um basically that if you say you're sick
when you're not then you will be sick
wow yeah and it's like it's the power of
our words
right our speech guys is extremely
powerful allah
takes at a point to mention in the quran
right he taught you how to speak he gave
you
intelligence yet so many of us think
that our words are not powerful
tell a child a few times that they suck
i wonder what's going to happen to them
tell a child that they're worthless
people complaining about their
self-esteem
parents are doing their children a
disservice
parents are telling their children
you're wrong you're this you're that it
gets ingrained in their heads because
our
words are powerful allah has taught the
human being how to speak
and the messenger sallallahu sallam told
us what and hadith
that hey if you have nothing kind to say
nothing good to say remain silent
he understood the power of our words he
understood how
our words can actually impact us so like
you're saying my bro
if you're sick you're sick it eventually
will come true it tells your entire
molecular your
your your physiology that you know i'm
sick there's something wrong with me i'm
sick
and you start going down that path so
forget about the stuff that our parents
have maybe told us what about the things
that we tell ourselves
right how many times have we told
ourselves that
sick but maybe spiritually sick
this email while i was waiting for you
while i was waiting for you i got this
email
rescue i feel like allah hates me i feel
like allah hates him
well if you keep telling yourself that
allah hates you what kind of mentality
are you going to have about allah
what kind of mindset are you going to
have how are you going to view allah
when allah tells us that he is to his
servant as he
believes him to be allah hates me allah
punish me allah
because you keep talking you have this
negative self
talk so if our words are in speech it's
so powerful with other people
imagine how many times we're cursing
ourselves
we're being our worst enemies we got to
really switch that up and be careful how
we use our speeches
yeah subhanallah 100 100 percent
very motivating and let this be a lesson
to myself you know the three of us
and to uh everyone watching subhanallah
and now i want to use this as
a point to move into my next question
which is about
dealing with people with emotional
intelligence i know i heard that
mashallah you were a schoolteacher
maybe perhaps you still are
alhamdulillah yes
you're on summer vacation summer break a
little needed little
rest you know just because it gets crazy
especially with kobe this year but
yes it reminds me um
i once heard that all the prophets were
sheep herders at one point
because they had to learn how to lead
the flock before they learned how to
lead humanity and their their people
and subhanallah i think there's a lot of
a lot to be learned from
people who have jobs oriented around
guiding people teaching people keeping
them organized and helping them grow
and you know children out of all people
subhanallah
could actually be the most difficult and
the most severe because you're actually
helping them morph into who they're
going to become in the future
so what would you say is the most or
some of the most important
uh traits to have when dealing with
people to motivate them
to to make them feel better and to just
deal with them with emotional
intelligence
i think that reminding people
and ourselves that you believe in them
you get what i mean like that's what the
messenger sallallahu was so good at he
was the
ultimate emotionally intelligent being
ever
like the best human being ever the most
emotionally intelligent thing ever
because he made sure that he gave
everyone value to a degree where a
companion came to the messenger
sallallahu and he asked him who his
favorite person was
and the messenger saw them kept on
rattling off names and the person name
you ever got
mentioned because you know he just
wasn't at that rank and you know the
messenger sausage was gonna tell him but
the reason he even asked the messenger
alaihissalam
is because he thought that his name was
gonna get mentioned in there because he
felt so
special and the messenger always made
people feel special so i think that one
thing that helps motivate people
one thing that helps encourage people is
showing that you believe
in them showing that you see a quality
in them that they might not be able to
see themselves i mean ask yourselves
guys right
you have this podcast now but this
really came about from someone else
encouraging you to do it if you think
about it like amongst each other yo we
got to do this we got to do this we got
to do this until someone's like yo
y'all really got to do this because an
outside perspective
brings a different type of belief in you
it allows you because we view ourselves
with a specific ceiling right over here
but someone else sees you for beyond
that and they push your ceiling a little
higher
so i'd say one thing that really helps
motivate people is believing in them and
showing them
a perspective of themselves that they're
unable to see
we have these blind spots and you
bringing that vantage point to them
i think really helps a person's soul
yeah i like that i like that because
i'll be honest with you man i grew up in
an environment where
it was very competitive and uh everyone
else was trying to
put each other down so it's like i
learned that
uh one i had to play these mental games
with people
in order to be able to one-up them and
then allow my uh physical abilities to
take uh
take over on that aspect but it's like
i've grown out of that i'm not in that
anymore
and now like whenever i'm with people
i find myself like holding back from
giving
that boost like saying something just to
lift them up
and then they'll say something to me and
i'll just stop i'm like damn
i i can't believe
holding back from giving that advice
your motivation like why do you find
yourself doing that oh
it's like i said it's just old
programming
i'm just saying i'm aware of it so like
what you're saying kind of just puts
everything into perspective like
copy that's what's needed it's needed to
lift each other up it's needed to say
those things where it's like
in our heads we might think ah it's
nothing like you know if i tell this
person this is not gonna do anything
but in reality that might be the thing
that that person needs the most within
that moment
true story one of my students
from sixth grade uh reconnected with
them and now
it's so it's just so crazy to connect
with my students now we're actually cool
because they're like older they're like
seniors in high school now and i'm like
they're middle school teachers so they
just vibe with me different now
and i remember randomly they hit me up
with a picture in the classroom
on a prayer mat and i said jack saying
a quote that i told them about excuses
about praying
and they had sent this to me and they
said that i still remember what you told
me in sixth grade and by
mind you this is like seven years later
now right because
the words that we we tell a person
should never be
underestimated good or bad good or bad
sometimes
we have these really we have terrible
memory any other time right but when
someone says something really nasty to
you you remember that forever like how
many times have you forgotten your phone
number
even your own name sometimes you always
forget those things but when someone
said something bad to you you always
remember that
and maybe we need to learn how to manage
our memories a little better and try to
remember the positive and the good
things that we've learned from
encounters with people
sometimes our brain just has this velcro
mechanism that only absorbs
what someone might have said that might
have you know could have been
potentially considered negative
when we need to remember that perhaps it
was a negative they were just feeling a
specific way
and they just unleashed whatever they
wanted to say onto you
so a lot of times when people say
something mean or harsh to you
we take it really personal when the the
matter of reality is it's not personal
it's how they're feeling about
themselves and they just take it on to
you
how many of you guys out there including
myself or your listeners out there
are really like had a bad day and they
took it out on someone they really loved
or cared about
right a person who they check it out or
takes it personal but the truth is it's
not personal it's how they were feeling
so
we need to be mindful that when we say
something we got to remember that this
could be with them for the rest of our
lives
and there's angels recording what we're
saying so let's be a little bit more
mindful with how we come off to people
and just come from a little bit more a
place of empathy
uh and and compassion when we speak to
others
yeah inshallah subhanallah it reminds me
of
a quote i heard from jordan peterson
where he said that people don't know how
little motivation
other people need they need such little
motivation if you could just give that
little bit to them they'd be so much
better off subhanallah
it's so important that we understand you
know the communal acts
at least to one another that we are um
maybe not
obligated uh to do maybe we are allahu
alam but for sure
we should at least be taking the um the
steps towards you know motivating other
people
but how about internally
personally to our own selves how do we
keep ourselves in check how do we keep
ourselves motivated
you know bro that's something that i
personally have been fighting with a lot
it's something that has bothered me it's
bugged me as
i'm sure it bugs a lot of your listeners
out there
um because sometimes going back to what
i said earlier
we have negative self-talk to ourselves
we're already feeling in a specific way
we're already having specific feelings
towards ourselves
and all of a sudden we have the talk
to match how we're already feeling
because we're already in a specific
state
i know one thing that helps me
personally is that if i am
able to get a few things done during my
day i feel like
like a success so if there's someone out
there struggling
with wondering like you know like how do
they feel more successful about
themselves
well give yourself something to feel
proud of right do something to make
yourself feel proud of
and that could be hey i went to the gym
today i prayed fajr today i went to the
gym today
and i read some quran whoa masha'allah
for some people they're having some
people might be dealing with you know
bipolar disorder or depression
and just them getting out of bed that
was a success believe it or not like
it's crazy what's happening of the
chemical imbalances and the things that
are going on in our minds and our hearts
that for them getting out of bed was a
success i say
try your best to
your victories try your best to just be
happy with your victories a little bit
because
let's suppose this is our goal right
over here okay and this is where we
start from
and perhaps we're like right over here
before getting to our goal
we think we're going to appreciate
things when we get to our goal and when
we look back at things i would argue
wherever you are look backwards look
downwards as to how far you've come
see the growth in you as a person see
how much you your your you know how much
you're developing and becoming because
if you start giving yourself a little
bit more credit
if you start finding reasons to be a
little bit more proud about yourself
finding reasons to celebrate certain
small wins because
small wins lead to the bigger victories
celebrate the small wins
and that's going to help you win and get
the larger victory win the battle itself
too so
why not look at our lives and say hey
what are some areas that i can be proud
of
whatever my life right whether i spoke
to my mom really kindly today
i was really obedient to my parents
today whether i prayed my salah on time
today
or i even attempted to read the quran
today
find reasons to be happy with yourself
to be proud of yourself
and to make it like a little checklist
that you know what give yourself a
little pat on the back because you know
masha'allah i'm making strides in the
right direction while being honest with
yourself so
to answer that question my bro i would
just genuinely say
find reasons to be proud of yourself
find
the little wins and the victories
because you have them
you just have to speak to yourself in a
more kinder way and and just remind
yourself that hey you're making the
progress you do what you have to do and
inshaallah everything is going to be all
right
that works for me at least honestly
amazing advice actually really reminds
me of something that uh both fide and
angel were telling me when i asked about
this when i inquired myself
and fired why don't you why don't you
talk about um the whole
negative um negative thoughts and energy
drainage and all of that
that you were telling me about bro i
would but we went
all in in the previous episode oh i'll
give yeah i'll give it like a little
snippet but before that
i had a quick question on my mind i
don't want to forget it but for
somebody that is struggling right now
with let's say their speech
right we know today rap music looking at
you know tv shows
people are cussing bro left and right
nobody has that haya in their in their
speech in their
in their words and their choice of words
some people might say it's very
cathartic right to use use some words
other people might say ah everyone's
doing it so what difference does it make
that i don't swear
so what advice would you give to a
brother or sister struggling with that
i think it all comes down to your
standard i have a really good brother of
mine he's a little brother of mine
and you know there's moments where in
their speech
you know they might curse they might
stay
drop an f-bomb or something like that
and look i'm not perfect i've done it
too
you know i mean none of us are perfect
over here we've all been in a frustrated
situation
where even the best of us maybe curse or
say something or let loose with our
speech
just a slight bit and i remember
speaking to this brother and i'm just
telling him not in the moment not in the
moment because you've got to be
coach you got to know when to correct
the person and this is what the
messenger salsa was so good at he knew
when to correct you
in front of people might not be the best
idea maybe privately through a text
maybe something
on the sly might be a better idea so i
remember talking to him
and immediately he was just like yeah
you're right i know and all that i said
listen bro
just be mindful you see there's
something about being self-aware and
mindful
that helps us become more responsible in
our speech
okay and sometimes we gotta make excuses
for the person that perhaps they were
feeling
a little overwhelmed maybe a little
frustrated and it slipped out of their
tongue
and give them the benefit of the doubt
think highly of them let them know that
listen when you speak like that it
actually brings your value down because
i'm surprised when you cross just
because you don't your
your frame your face and all this it
doesn't seem like the person
of someone who does cursor uses that
type of language so when you said that
it sort of took you know took me back a
little bit when you put
people in a situation where you think
really highly of them
that's when they start thinking highly
of themselves sometimes and you're right
my bro
uh you know if you you made a good point
about you know the company that we're in
sometimes it's just the norm
well that means that we got to upgrade
the company that we're in you know and
i've been around people who curse
so much that it came into my vocabulary
once and i
and i didn't realize that whoa this
actually infiltrated my vocabulary
and sometimes when we're around the
wrong people around the wrong friends
and the messenger sallallahu alaihi gave
us very clear parameters
or of who you should consider a friend
and who we should give this rare title
to
we shouldn't just like call everyone our
besties that's not how this should be
friendship is a title that should be
very unique and
specific to a person so if you call
someone a friend do they remind you of
allah do they remind you to fear allah
do they remind you of the day of
judgment there's certain qualities that
they need to have to be considered
your friend it's an elite title that a
person should have but
when you're around people who are not
the best of influences then
sometimes the same way if you're in a
house of a person who smokes cigarettes
you might not even take a drag yourself
but your jacket your coat your clothes
everything
comes smelling like that little
cigarette smell
so if you're around the wrong people
naturally
their standards become yours okay so if
their standards are to curse
your standards becomes cursed if their
standards are to be
rude to their parents your standards
become rude to your parents so
i would always challenge a person to see
who your company is
because i promise you you would never
see me around people
who are not at a level that i'm trying
to bring them up to or a level that i'm
trying to get to
i'm never below anyone else from that
level and i'm sure you guys are too
you make sure that who's in your circle
of friends and who's in your company
because you want to make sure that you
want to benefit and they could get some
benefit from you too so a person who's
struggling out there with your speech
i would ask you what's the source of
this what's the source
it probably is your friend it probably
is the music like you mentioned my bro
so if that's the case ask yourself what
are your standards are you
okay with allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
taking this tongue and asking it a
specific question
how can this tongue that makes dua that
praise to allah
recites quran be the same tongue that
curses
it just doesn't make sense and it's just
a complete oxymoron to why
allah created this tongue for you and if
you are protecting
that which between your jaws and between
your legs your private parts and your
your tongue allah will promise you
paradise so perhaps this is your
struggle this is your test
and if you protect it and safeguarded
your tongue your speech
maybe this is what's going to cause you
to enter jannah who knows
allah
yeah i like the fact that you said make
sure you make sure
you have releases it has to have a
clickbaity title it has to have a
clickbaity
uh thumbnail all that sort of stuff
because with me you gotta have that sort
of stuff this is listen listen bro
when we started youtube i'm gonna say
this you know drop this in before
another takes over
i was kind of like you know content is
the only thing that matters putting a
video you know
and we were doing okay we were getting
some numbers but i realized at one point
i was having a conversation with angel
and we realized like it is a game right
like just like you said
the competition youtube really is a game
and if you don't play the game
you lost by definition so you gotta play
the game and to get good at the game you
need to do numbers
so we started putting a little bit of
effort we're not going to use like weird
clickbait that has nothing to do with
the video
absolutely absolutely you got to stay
through it authentic yeah
yeah yeah definitely definitely glad you
mentioned that my bro i'll tell what
were you saying bro
i'm loving the hat by the way i just
want to say that you want
that's my team bro that's my team i'm
from phoenix arizona bro i've been
i've been through the worst with these
teams bro like we've been the
laughingstock for a
very long time a very very long time but
alhamdulillah
things have turned things have gotten
better so it's feeling good to be a suns
fan man but at the end of the day
it's in the hands of allah and you know
i don't want to you know it's just
basketball at the end day like no matter
how much i care about to love them
it's still a fitness that's still a test
for me
because the same team has been i've been
struggling to make up for fudger because
of these guys because these east coast
games bro
are no joke show me so you know it
sounds all the way though inshallah we
win though
yeah yeah i feel you i feel you man i i
was just with my boy
and he's rooting for the sons as well he
wants to see uh
chris paul get a ring
yeah oh wait that'd be nice bro he gets
this is he on the song or is he on the
other one yes sir
yeah yes sir yeah and you know there's
something about
rooting for the person who's been
patient right there's something about
being patient and seeing the people who
are patient
when that's why the messenger
sallallahu's story is so amazing
because he was patient he was patient he
was patient getting stoned and died
all this drama happening to him and then
all of a sudden he goes to medina
and things just get so much better but
we wouldn't appreciate it he wouldn't
appreciate it if allah
on the second day took him to medina
like that's how life works we got to be
patient
we got to enjoy that underdog story we
got to enjoy the struggle because
when things are going to get better
you're going to what what's what's
creating this muscle even with you guys
even with me
struggling to get the views you know
struggling to get people's attention
that's teaching you a muscle so that
when you do break through
you're stronger than the rest because
it's developing your character
for everyone else who just got it on the
first shot you know maybe they just got
some clout maybe their heads got bigger
and when tough times and calamities came
about their way they don't know how to
deal with it
but you and i we got that muscle we know
how to go through
with how do we deal with these waves how
do we deal with lower numbers because
it's making us stronger
and there's something about being
patient being patient and then getting
the fruit which tastes so much better so
stay patient
stay hungry and inshaallah things are
coming your way inshallah bro
what you what you achieve is not not
nearly as important as who you've become
in the process
[Music]
definitely definitely and some people
lose themselves in the process
um going back to what you were saying
though about the
language i like how you said that you
got to be mindful
because i i was telling fire that a
while back like during ramadan
i had took it upon myself i was you know
what i'm have a real clean
tongue in this ramadan i'm not gonna
curse
and uh i'm not gonna sit here and act
like i didn't
but i did my best and what i noticed is
that
i would be super super mindful and it
would actually make me more
present and more like in tune with uh
my thoughts and just the conversations
that i was having with other people
but man just being mindful that's
that's a huge one to be able to to get
past it so i'm glad you uh you mentioned
that one
bro bro for sure and one thing i would
challenge you
and you know challenge you to just push
you a little bit further
is that if you do slip apologize
in the moment wallahi there's something
about associating pain and pleasure that
the human being
is with that makes us act different so
if if that cause if it would cause you
pain to own your mistake in front of
people and you end up doing
it just to avoid that pain in the future
you're going to make sure that your
tongue doesn't curse again
so if you do end up slipping or whatever
it's a mistake of how
may allah forgive us it happens it's a
mistake but if you do end up making that
mistake just say excuse me i'm sorry
about that sorry
excuse me just quickly i mean
makes people respect you even more to be
honest no no i was fired but every time
i curse i'm like oh i still feel low
there we go yeah and they would be like
oh bro it's all right like i'm like no
no no i know it's all right but i'm the
one that said that i don't want to do
this
so i feel like i'm going against myself
but more importantly i'm going against
allah
if i said that i'm not going to do it
and i'm going to do it
you know that's why bro that's why as
muslims we we have to dress a certain
way we can't we have to talk a certain
way we can't just be
like everyone else we can't just be like
mainstream
uh status quo because a lot of the time
especially today unprecedented
status quo was actually not really
resourceful for anyone's mental health
you know physical health just
self-improvement nothing
so it's in our best interest that we try
to stay the teachings of allah
definitely bro it's in our own benefit
like you said and
it's our it's our user manual if you're
not gonna you know use that manual
my question is what other user manual
are you using because you definitely are
we as human beings are programmed for
guidance it's just how we are
we look up to certain people this you
know this is a new having celebrity
culture isn't new this is something
that's always been within us for people
to look up to
so the so allah always sent the best of
human beings so that you could admire
and look up to
but guess what if someone really wants
to admire isa alaihissalam
i'm sorry but it's just not there it's
just not recorded
it's just not present for you to really
model yourself
after this man's character even though
i'm sure he had an amazing character
if you want to model yourself after musa
al-islam i'm sorry but
you just can't model yourself as a
perfect human being after him not
because he wasn't a perfect human being
just because the technology available at
the time
didn't exist for them to record his
his the way he stood up the way he you
know dressed the way he walked the way
he moved the way he spoke
it just didn't exist at the time so the
so allah sent the best of human beings
the best of mankind
to us the messenger sallallahu alaihi
muhammad
peace and blessings be upon him and
everything about this man is recorded
so that we can emulate him to our best
abilities from our diet through our
physique through
everything that we want to do and this
is a claim that no one else can make
about their prophet
and guess what that's what gives us a
level above other people
and the hadith knowing about the sunnah
and the seerah is bro what makes our
religion so much more
uh fruitful and beautiful because other
people don't have this
mashallah bro next thing on my mind is
tell us a few things that you've learned
being a father wow
bro i've learned i've learned a lot of
things man i've learned
one i'm not i'm not the man that i
want them to look up to and that's
something that really took time for me
to admit
and even it hurts to admit it now
in front of a podcast i've heard so many
people uh you know potentially watching
this
that i wasn't the man that i wanted my
children
to see or to be and the cool thing about
that is that it pushed me
uh to become better because a true story
when my my
my eldest was born dua and i was holding
her
you know and i wanted to just hold her
and recite quran
read quran and recite it i didn't know
how to
and her being born pushed me
to go and learn quran so i then after
that i just sat in the masjid i got the
teachers
i let i didn't stop until i was able to
recite quran
you know so what i'm saying the reason
i'm just giving you that that's just one
example
right of who i'm trying to be but what
i've learned as a father is that i'm not
perfect
i'm not this you know ideal person that
i want to be
yet but i'm working in that direction
and whether you are you're not
there's people who are looking up to you
these children look up to you you are
their everything believe it or not
and it is my responsibility along with
you know my wife's responsibility and
our family unit's responsibility
to make raising these children upon the
quran and the sunnah
because the same way that i'm competing
for their attention
youtube is competing for their attention
and there's so many other things and
they're going to start school soon too
so i'm learning as a father that i need
to do my absolute best to be the role
model that i actually want them to see
and that starts with me making sure that
my speech around them is right bro
angel if you really want to make sure
that you don't curse though be around
some children bro when you have some
children i promise you bro
because if these kids say something
they're gonna be like they heard it from
one of us
you feel me so you're teaching them
without knowing and i and i realized
being a father that
i am the ultimate teacher for them
because they are learning
from me and that just caused me to be a
little bit more on my
you know piece of cues just you know
cross my teeth dot my eyes a little bit
more
just because i know someone's watching
me even more and they're sponges
so you know it's just it's just they're
so influential
and easily influential and they're
easily influenced
and i just have to make sure that i am
being the best of influences upon them
so that's something i learned
it's beautiful i feel like i feel like
your energy is uh
trying to explode i feel like it the
real you would be standing up
listen listen listen the real one listen
i find trouble
i don't like sitting it's just something
about me i don't i like standing up
and just being there my tripod wasn't
aligning correctly from a webcam
that i'm using otherwise i'd be standing
around and just going nuts you know but
but i appreciate you guys i really wish
that we could just like
sit down and have this this this podcast
you know like i wanna i wanna give a
shout out to my brother tai
uh who put me on to you guys uh and
he was the one who actually hit you guys
up saying that hey you need to get this
guy over here
and uh that's a revert friend of mine
and uh
you know i just have so much love from
respect for him because
uh i'm assuming you're a revert correct
yes and bro dealing and the struggles of
a reaver are not easy so
shout out to you shout out to tai shout
out to all the reverts out there
for doing their hardest to stay on their
deen while their entire surroundings are
not on their deen you know parents are
not bringing
the halal food inside the fridge and
there's so many other things eid
feels like you're all alone there's so
many things going on but shout out to
all the reverts out there
your patience is what's going to take
you to paradise to just stay strong
yeah 100 man and that's actually
how i found your video fired send me
the one you made about your tattoos and
your clickbaity title with uh i'm
getting rid of all of them or something
like that
um bro it's like i have tattoos all over
my body
and if i were to get the surgery or not
surgery but the laser
removal that's over 150 k that's over 10
years of getting this
this treatment done it's like for a
while for wow and people don't people
don't even realize the
pain and the amount of procedures the
amount of times that you have to go for
one setting
because each tattoo depending on color
depending on age has a different amount
of
like sessions that they need and it
hurts and have you ever seen the
blisters that happen after that bro
they are scary looking they're scared
and they scar the body way worse than
any tattooing does but however right
what's a cheaper alternative is
something called tawba
it's something called istanbul that's a
cheaper alternative because
what happens is i i found that a lot of
people and there's nothing may allah
bless all those who actually choose to
go down the path
of tattoo removal i mean good for you
but to make it a requirement
to to make it seem like you're more
sincere than i am or i'm not sincere
enough because i haven't done it it's
absolutely false
because if we're not talking about the
money forget get the money
if we're not talking about the pain
forget the pain the fact that i
and allah subhanahu ta'ala have sorted
it out
what's it to you you know i mean the
problem is that people are expressing
their
own pains onto you whether it's jealousy
because they always wanted one but they
can't have one and they hate you for
having one and being on your theme
whether there's jealousy of how can this
guy have best of both worlds he can't
have his cake and eat it too
have tattoos and you talk about islam
people don't like that
people don't like to see the fact that
you know that that a person's doing well
and they could turn back to allah
and they could have a past behind them
but in all honesty and
i think that what that's what makes you
a little bit more
cooler attractive more i want to get to
know more about you
if i'm about the dean i'm studying i
want an abroad tell me more about you
tell me more about your story you know
imagine how much
da that is imagine how many youth could
come to that
and at the same time it's not like
you're saying you're proud of them in
fact you're not proud of them
but they made you who you are each
tattoo
each scar tells a different story about
who you used to be
and alhamdulillah if it wasn't for who
you used to be
you wouldn't be the person in front of
me right now so we need to celebrate our
past a little bit more
stop hating on yourself a little too but
stop regretting it to the degree
where you hate the person that you were
yes you hate who you were but you got to
love the person that you've become
because of that you got to love who you
become right now and who you become
right now is a servant of allah
is a worship of allah you are not your
past you are not your tattoos you're not
your sins
they don't define who you used to be
what defines you
is your salah what defines you is your
love of allah love of islam love of his
messenger allah salaam so
you know whoever struggled with tattoos
out there or has a
sin of something that seems noticeable
don't let that drag you down
don't take it personal people just
expressing their own
ill feelings that they have about
themselves on to you
they're projecting on to you so don't
take it personal
just know that be patient with this and
allah will take care of the rest and
your patience is elevating your status
in paradise
so keep on and carry on amen 100
i feel too that a lot of people have the
good intention
to give the nasia to give the advice but
it's like look
you should only give nasi ha at least in
my opinion you should only give nasia
if you yourself are doing everything
possible to take care of yourself
and your dean and the way that you're
doing things because if not
if you're not doing everything possible
well then you giving someone else nasiha
is
is kind of empty it's kind of uh
incomplete if you know what i mean and
it can i can
definitely i'm sorry i didn't mean to
cut you off go ahead bro
i want to i want to push your thinking a
little bit so let's suppose
i'm maybe watching pornography
i'm doing may allah protect us from
pornography from zina
from all these other haram things that
we can do privately aloha
i mean let's suppose i'm watching
pornography i know it's haram
i feel bad about this haram the first
thing is the fact that i feel bad
even if i might we continue to do it
there's a sense of iman in there
that means that there's something i
could i could fight this i could do this
with the right help of course i can
fight it
let's suppose you come to me with the
problem pornography
or i see you watching porn or i find out
that you're watching porn
should i not give you them to see how to
stop
yeah you should there we go there we go
even
even if i'm not following my own to see
how i should still give you
however that doesn't that doesn't mean i
shouldn't practice what i preach
it means that there's certain times
nasiha certain sins
certain you know the gravity of that sin
is so much
that i got gotta stop you even if i'm
one who commits it myself
i gotta still stop you from doing it yes
we're never gonna be perfect you know
but the problem is that when these
people are giving them the cia and they
have good intention thank you bro angel
for
pointing out the fact that they do have
good intentions because they do
because they absolutely do and we as
people we should remember our being
is nasiha we should assume that they
have good intentions we should assume
that someone is telling us
about the tattoos or about something out
of out of love
okay baby thank you so much i love you
i'm sorry you know you came in
do you have to tell me something because
we're we're fasting right now she's
telling me about the food that's going
to be ready for bunker so
she's like so anyway going back to it
right you know
sometimes the nasia is great in
everything and we should always take the
nesiga
we should always take the nasir because
they mean good by it but at the same
time
the person giving them asiha if we're
giving this year we also like you said
need to check ourselves
check ourselves protect ourselves from
the hypocrisy so that's an excellent
point that you mentioned my bro
and to add to that my bad rami i feel
like you you've been wanting to go in
here so
let me just add one little bit here so
to add on to like this last thing here
everything that we've said
is 100 true and then it's it's all about
the delivery
so if if the person is checking
themselves if the person is
doing everything possible their delivery
of that nasiha is going to be a lot more
impactful a lot more powerful and a lot
more
pure than if they are not really
checking themselves they are
you know they they're kind of being
hypocrites here you know what i'm saying
yeah yeah yeah and we look when we give
the siha
we just need to do it in the most
beautiful manners possible with the most
emotional intelligence possible
but the most amount of patience possible
like if i saw you something doing
something right that wasn't didn't need
major correction right now
right it wasn't like a major major sin
it needs correction but
not at this moment it's not detrimental
to your deen it's something that
it could improve your deen but it's not
detrimental and let's suppose i know
that rami has a better relationship than
i do with you
it's not necessary that i got to give
you the the advice or the nisiha and
hell
sometimes i can ask rami to do it for
you or someone who's closer to you
because you would listen and take
obviously to see how a little bit more
serious perhaps
than you would take mine who's a
complete stranger to you you understand
so with our nasiha we need to be more
intelligent that
hey what is it that's more important to
me me giving them to see her
or them actually applying it a lot of us
sometimes just want to be right and say
i gave them to see her and they didn't
take it
so that means they're wrong you know
they oh you know
i gave them that they see how but
they're not listening to us they don't
listen they're not sincere
sometimes we just want to give them this
year for the sake of this he had to say
we did it
and even if they're not ready to take it
bro is a seed
that you plant if you think that there's
going to be a tree or plant as soon as
you plant it
it is your problem not theirs give it
some time
water it be nice to it become friends
with them
help them in the process before just
planting a scene and be like yo
where's it at where's the tree at so
being mindful reaching to see how being
and going back to the example of hussein
you know guess what they saw a man
performing well doing correctly
they could have been they could have
flexed that you know they're the
grandchildren of the messenger saw so
that mean
me i could do whatever i want to say and
say to you you have to listen to me
because i know better than you do
but they didn't do that they made it in
a clever way that one they're saying hey
can you settle this debate between us
you know i say the brother was this way
he's saying we'll lose this way can you
watch us both and tell us who's doing it
correctly
and upon seeing that the man realized
what he was doing and was able to do the
correction he self-corrected himself
so we need to be more mindful when it
comes to decency
one quick uh one quick thing on my mind
bro at this point rami's never going to
go
uh my bad bro so if
we have a man or a woman who is a reaver
they have converted to islam accepted
the dean and they're trying to get on
dean
how can they now put their people on
dean
should they should they not does it
matter um let's say parents friends
what should they do you know
the mess center is awesome in the second
revelation that was given which was in
surah al-budafi
where the messenger alaihissalam was
instructed
to get up in the middle of the night and
to pray to allah azzawajal
then he was instructed to go and spread
the deen itself too
i think that a lot of times reverts and
anyone who has a lot of love for the
dean
always wants to help others before they
help themselves first you know
when a person is waking up for tahajid
and that time like allah is recommended
at that time no one else is up between
you and allah that's it it's just yatu
you know i mean
and that gives you a lot of time for
self-reflection and for you to work on
yourself
before you start going to work on other
people because there's a saying that
you know you can't fill someone else up
with a half a
pitcher i've completely butchered that
same but something about a pitcher
and if you're half empty and you're
trying to fill so it's something like
that i've butchered it completely but
it's something like that right
when you wake up with the hajjit as like
the messenger sausage being recommended
to do before
he's instructed to go give the da'wah it
allows him
to do his meditation his self-reflection
to write himself to center himself
before tackling on the da'wah so my
advice to anyone who has a lot of love
for the deen a lot of compassion for the
deen a lot of energy towards the dean
or as a reaver it just wants to spread
the message of islam because
that's what they want to do and they
love it and they want to
spread that love make sure that you
write yourself first
at least during the day before inviting
other people because i
myself invited people in the most
wrongful way possible
i invited people to islam in the
harshest way the wrongest way i think i
put people off from islam
the same way that you see me now able to
speak to people to put people on
make them have a love for the dean i did
the exact opposite in the beginning
because i used to push people away from
the dean
so harsh like you they said yo you're
the reason i don't want to be a muslim
forgive me for that you know
sometimes we get so excited that we
don't have the packaging for it you know
so being a little patient with your
dawah
is good i mean the messenger is awesome
didn't receive the second revelation
until
a long period of time which gave him
time to appreciate to learn to reflect
so you know just because you accepted
islam doesn't mean that you immediately
have to give
out tawa with your speech but your
actions is a great way to
give dawah at first you know when you're
still learning about your deen
give give dawah with the actions don't
be too quick to
jump in and start teaching people about
the beam because we all are still
learning in this process
around me bro i mean if it's not if it's
not now then it's going to be never so
going
uh firstly i want to say i don't mind
not speaking that's why i'm not really
you know pushing for it if i thought my
point was urgent then i'd get it out
there insha'allah but it's just a little
hard on and that question masha allah
i'm glad i didn't go because of how
important that question was so
um to you for asking for ask you for
answering may allah bless all of you
i was just going to say on the point of
the tattoos and everything the
difference between a tattoo
and every other sin right is it it stays
with you it's
it's on your body right the same way a
woman wears her hijab and it's
very clear she's a muslim a person may
wear a tattoo and it's very clear that
okay
perhaps i had a jahilia it's very
obvious but
to attack that way of thinking it's like
subhan allah imagine just think about
the sahaba radhila
all the sahaba that didn't accept islam
as children and who were important to
islam
what do you think they were doing before
they accepted islam
was fighting against muslims he led the
the um the attack on when uh the archers
went down from the hill
wow wow wow the same muslim that ended
up leaving
leading the muslims to victory later on
so you're going to sit here like all
this guy's tattoos you know this stuff
the other
you know maybe kicked them out of the
magic because of that wow
which happened which has definitely
happened before and can i just say to
add to the point bro
you know that's one of the biggest
reasons
that stops people from coming to the
deen that right there
the fear of judgment the fear of their
sins the fear of their sins being too
much that allah's mercy
and going back to khalid waleed so
khalid's brother comes
to madina right and the messenger he
says take me to the messenger
alaihissalam so anyone when they came
from mecca
they came to show they came to show
their loyalty to the to the
to rasulullah sallallahu salaam and
coming and explain to himself and
and the messenger of allah he knew who
who was the leader he knew who was
attacking who
he knew everything and when he saw his
brother he asked the question to him
he said where's khalid where's khalid
someone so intelligent as khalid not
being a muslim just
doesn't make sense and it wasn't until
this happened
that we seen khalid relief entering the
city of madinah
and he comes to the messenger of allah
and he tells the people take me to the
messenger
and when he goes to uh uh you know uh
muhammad sallallahu alaihi sallam he
says ya rasulullah
i've done this i've killed the muslims
i've attacked the muslims
you name it you name it you think
tattoos are bad
killing muslims come on bro leading
armies to kill
strategizing how to destroy you this is
bad
please you need to study a little bit
more he said i've done this i've done
this i've done this
how how can i be forgiven
and the messenger sallallahu alaihi
wasallam response
it says don't you know that islam
forgives everything
so i'm asking you out there listener
don't you know that islam forgives
everything you think it's the tattoo
that's stopping you you think it's a
jahalia that's stopping you
or is it you sincerely turning back to
allah
is it you having the humility to own
your mistakes and say allah
i'm ready to come to you allah i'm ready
to start fresh allah
let's make this happen let me submit to
you ya rabi
because i was wrong but now i'm ready to
write my wrongs which one is it
because allah is ready to forgive you
the question is are you ready to ask for
that forgiveness
powerful man that's the coming up bro
that's coming up
and guys if you made it this far don't
be salty that the clickbaity thumbnail
or title that you saw
isn't actually what went on we got to do
it to you you made it this far though so
it's all that matters right
you've made it this far yes they're
programmed they don't even know it's
like sometimes i'm going through sq's um
time stamps and i'm just like bro why am
i even reading this
yeah just like you know you just just go
through
them and then but you know what i'm
saying you know as
as this podcast is coming down why bro i
as as this podcast comes to mind i just
want to say i'm so honored and humbled
that you guys invited me to this um you
know i honest to god like i just
appreciate you guys so much and i
appreciate what you guys do for the
ummah
for the youth because they need we need
diversity we
need people who could see themselves in
an unhealth
we need people who see themselves in a
rami and uh
you know what i mean we need people
people see themselves in you and i know
we are not we're not telling people to
look up to us we know that
but there's something about
representation that makes it more
attractive you know
there's representation and i see three
beautiful brothers masha'allah
with such a dynamic representation that
makes muslims for all walks of life to
be like
i could vibe to this i can i could i
could really you know go on with this
right over here i could i could get with
this because this islam thing shows how
many people are connected in different
ways so
i'm just so honored i'm so humbled that
you guys even chose to invite me
and i pray that this is not the last
podcast rather this is the first of many
and i hope that i'm i'm a special guest
uh many times on your podcast because
honest to god you guys are just
such awesome people and this was a lot
of fun and uh if anyone did make it over
here which i know a lot of people would
have
made it over here just know that if you
need anything whatsoever i want to
make myself fully available to you all
uh just message me dm me
on instagram and just say hey i came
from the three muslim podcast
okay say hey sq i heard your thing i
came from three muslim podcasts flagged
me
and i'm just gonna flag anyone who comes
from this podcast so you have direct
access to me
you dm me immediately i'll respond to
you as well inshallah
and just make sure you say you came from
this podcast so i could give you that
type of
sort of uh you know treatment just
because i appreciate you guys so much
and i appreciate you guys having me
on this podcast as well like we we
should give people a qr code
type type in uh hold up i got the uh
this thing on here type in
sq6b2 to get 15 percent
off that's it that's the type of sq 6b2
for the discount code on your on your
black seed oil
you know whatever
you already know you already know listen
guys also i appreciate you and you know
your your audience are probably seeing
these um just know uh
we basically are the first people to
ever in the history
of zum zum's release to ever
commercially import
zum-zum on such a massive scale into
america and in canada
prior to this this never happened and we
brought this for two reasons to
give access to zamzam water to muslims
in america and canada
and to help the umma because 100 of the
profits that get sold from these bottles
go straight to helping build a free
public school
in philistine i'm a schoolteacher for
nearly a decade
so i know what it takes to run a school
how important schooling is and we want
to build a free public school in
philistine so
whoever buys zem zom from us immediately
is going towards the prophets are going
straight to them and inshallah august
1st we are traveling to palestine
inshallah
to search for the land that we're going
to build this school upon guys so
i appreciate you guys letting me plug
this in this water over here
gave the meccans financial freedom and
abu muttalib
found in a dream where this water was
prior to that they were getting skinned
they were just losing so much money they
weren't allowed to get the water
but when abu mutalib found where the
water was because it was
it was like lost for a while this
gave mecca the power they put them back
in the driver's seat and it gave them
the financial freedom to become
the nation that they became and we are
doing the same thing by
bringing accessibility to this water to
muslims america american and canadians
and just the ummah we want to bring
financial freedom to
the bus to this palace
next time it's yemen next time it's
building water wells in gambia
next time is putting solar panels in you
know ghana
it's building free food pantries in
yemen so people who just come
and eat and get the food and ration
their food free
without ever having to ask any
permission all throughout the year
and this is going to bring us inshallah
the financial freedom
uh by by investing in the zamzam getting
it for you and your loved ones
your family and then that money gets
invested into the omaha so
guys i appreciate you allowing me to do
this little plug-in
let's say there's somebody who wants to
actually purchase this insha allah
where can they go to get some great
question my bro it is at
project zamzam.com go to project
zumfum.com you are one click away
from you know you receiving your zamzam
and i promise you like
this is the real authentic you know if
you've been to hajj um you know what
this is right
bro it would mean the world to me if you
went and got some zamzam because you're
supporting the project and
at the same time we're going to
philistine in the first week of august
so we need all the help we could get the
more money we have the more support we
have for this
uh the the better we can help the
quicker we can help the ummah but may
allah bless you guys i appreciate you
once again i mean
this link in description box get your
bottle now appreciate that
thank you thank you sir send it to
someone who will buy and shall listen to
your family your uncles your aunts
insha'allah people who want zamzam are
complaining that oh we don't have access
to it canada america
now they do allah
only place to ever get it is with us
that's that's
that's kind of crazy but it's the only
place to ever get it is with us any
other place is just not available so
i appreciate you all once again thank
you of course it touches all ours
those who made it this far comment down
bring back sq
so we can do more episodes with him in
sha allah
do it bless you and the two brothers
with me today
being said if you guys don't have any
final words
i think the last thing that i want to
say bro is that i admire your passion
there's a there's a compliment for you
man keep it going
thank you thank you thank you for thank
you for spreading the goodness bro and
thank you for
uh saying nice things because you don't
know how much i might have needed that
you know i mean you don't know how much
i might have needed that so
thank you for putting that out there i
appreciate you my bro
i got you bro i got you well and thank
you for being here
yeah man listen until next time
we're gonna we're gonna just go on
instagram and follow each other and do
all that good stuff too we're gonna be
friends from this pray on inshallah god
and with that being said
[Music]
he would think ah yeah like my plan is
aligned with the last playing because
everything is
functioning so smoothly but then out of
nowhere there's a sticking point and
like
nothing's happening and to him he's like
going crazy and he's pretty much second
out or second guessing doubting
and uh just chaotic for like a better
words
but it's in that time where he needs to
be as patient as possible
and continue to trust in the creator and
continue to do
whatever it is he started doing keeping
the same energy that he started with
in order for him to pass the test
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
um